Good morning, Hank! It's Monday of "How-to" week
and today I am going to fulfill the most common request we received,
and tell you, how to make a baby.
Which, as it happens, is one of my fields of expertise
and as you can see, I have several fields of expertise.
Okay, so, some people will tell you that making a baby is a one-step process,
particularly if you are a dude, but those people are wrong.
In fact, it is a seven-step process,
Step 1: Before you are gonna make a baby of your own, you're gonna
wanna check out a baby that someone else has made.
From this experience, you will likely learn that, 1) babies are cute and 2),
babies are monsters of
narcissism who believe that there has
never been another human being in the
history of the world and who also
believe deep down in their tiny little
baby souls the you exist solely for the
purpose of attending to their needs.
In fact, I would argue that whether you find babies cute is not necessarily relevant to whether you
enjoy having a baby
Step 2: Okay, say, you go to bed at 11 p.m. Set
your alarm for midnight,
wake up and listen to this for 20 minutes *baby crying* then set your alarm for 2 a.m.
wake up and listen to this for 20 minutes and so on every two hours
24 hours a day for two weeks. No breaks. Okay, so, having done
that you're now ready for Step 3
there are several ways to take Step three, from test tubes to Turkey basters,
but by far the most common is to have sex.
Alright, so, that was fun. Step 4, if you're a
woman it's time to give up sushi and
caffeine and alcohol and go-karts and
most of the other things that make life
worth living. But the good news is that, now. you get to vomit all the time.
Or if you're a dude you get to stand
outside the bathroom door listening to
vomit and thinking to yourself very
quietly because you know from experience
that the person you love the most in the
world can sometimes hear your thoughts.
That person, I love most in the world,
sure was less cranky when she used to
drink coffee and
not vomit so much. Step 5: if you are
the person giving birth
it is time to do the hardest core thing
you will ever do in your entire life.
If you are not the person giving birth
this would be a great time to say
,"You're doing awesome." and then, faint.
Step 6: the baby cries. Step 7: You cry
Which begins a dramatic increase in the
total number of minutes
people are crying inside your house and
that in 7 easy steps
is Hank, how you make a baby at which
point it becomes socially inappropriate
for you to wear your zombie unicorn hat
even though you are still young at heart.
Nerdfighters, we are doing more "How-to"
videos this week so leave your
suggestions for what you'd like us to
teach you how to do in the comments. Hank, I gotta go upstairs
and do daddy stuff. But I will see
you on Wednesday.